thank you all for coming we have a task
here we have six highly distinguished
panelists and something less than 90
minutes to solve the world's problems
six months ago it was six months ago now
that the Lehman debacle occurred that
AIG was rescued that Bank of America
bought Merrill Lynch about six months
ago that the tarp funds started being
distributed only on Monday are we going
to find out what's really on the bank
balance sheets this frightens me we've
been operating it seems to me with so
little information the the so-called
stress test will be out I think it says
something about the way government has
managed this economy the economy was
doing fairly poorly in much of 2008 and
then fell off a cliff in the last
quarter of two thousand eight and into
2009 growing falling at a six percent
annual rate an extraordinary dropped in
our national income it is now by some
very important measures the worst
economic recession and post World War
two the post World War two ERA
employment has dropped faster than ever
before in this space of time industrial
production and by many other criteria
it's almost the worst and it isn't over
yet the one last thing i want to say
what gives us all the jitters is that
this is a three font front problem a
housing market that went crazy and the
bubble burst a credit crisis the most
severe we've known since the early 1930s
and now a sharp drop in demand for goods
and services and capital investment
leading to a severe recession what gives
us the jitters is that all of these are
related and can make all those other
factors worse I'm not going to talk
anymore because we want to hear what our
panelists have to say my job is to try
to keep us to time I've asked each of
them to comment in the first six or
seven minutes in their introductory
remarks
on what the current state of the economy
is many people are saying they're green
shoots we have seen some deceleration in
the decline of the economy green shoots
are showing what is the actual state of
the economy and do we need a serious
mid-course correction on the part of the
government do we have to change policy
and what we should do all of that in six
or seven minutes for each of us let's go
immediately to Senator Bradley and again
I will try and keep us on time senator
oh thanks very much Jeff it's an honor
for me to be on this panel I look around
it distinguished historians and
economists and fit in sears and wonder
what I'm doing here but I assume that
I'm here because I think that any
solution to the problem certainly even
defining the problem that we're facing
has to be able to be defined so the
average guy understands and the solution
to the problem has to be given so that
the slightly above average guy
understands so how are we along the
recovery I mean when citicorp drops from
60 to 1 and then comes back to three I
don't think that's a recovery when
Warren Buffett buys GE and Goldman Sachs
and after he buys that it drops forty
five to fifty percent and that if he's
going to even break even he's got her
nine percent for the next 12 years I
don't think that's a recovery if you
look at what we should do about this on
the one hand the administration has put
in place measures that if they were to
work could offer some hope what I'd like
to suggest is if they don't work there's
an alternative and I'd like to put it
this way you know we have essentially
spent about 12 point seven trillion
dollars in commitments and actually
spent a little over four trillion
dollars in this crisis some institutions
such as citicorp for example received
about 60 billion in direct assistance
and 340 billion
in guarantees so the US taxpayers in the
city core for about four hundred billion
dollars so i look at this and i say if
we look out to june july and the ppi
program is not succeeding the assets
aren't being bought at levels that they
should be bought from the banks of book
from the books of banks that there is an
alternative because in the interim
between now and then there will have
been a stress test few banks will be
identified who knows it might even be
postponed and also secretary Geithner
will have the authority to come in and
deal effectively and forcefully with
non-bank financial institutions so when
I look out to July August ppi p isn't
working the stress tests have been
delayed there was an argument about to
have whether the government is right of
the banks are right but clearly there
are a few that are in very serious
problems and you have the secretary with
that new authority you think back to
city core we put 400 billion dollars
into it I looked at the ticker today the
market cap of city core 17 billion
dollars so the government could buy city
core for a fraction of what we've
already obligated the taxpayer for and
in buying city core as an example could
be another one or two others it
wouldn'ta government announced in four
to six months we're going to sell these
assets the good assets back to the
public who wouldn't pay for the largest
depositor base in the world and if you
bought city core for let's say 20
billion dollars what would it be worth
if you sold the good bank back to the
public and I mean the public I don't
mean selling it to hedge funds although
they can participate but I would do it
as a rights offering to any American who
wants to invest in this good bank I
think the very prospect of that
happening would be bring very strong
positive
of influence on the development of the
whole economy and what would the
government then be left with the
government would then be left with the
bad bank it would be left with the
assets that were going through loops now
to try to get off of the bank books and
instead the government would happen we
could take 20 to 15 to 20 years to clean
them up so when I look at this I say I'd
like to see the existing program work if
it doesn't work there is an alternative
and it's an alternative than the long
run the average guy in America could
participate in Thank You senator just
six minutes very impressive professor
Fergusson well Jeff panelists ladies and
gentlemen we are living through historic
times this is the end of the age of
leverage which began I guess in the late
1970s and saw an explosive rise are in
the ratio of debt to gross domestic
product not only in this country but in
many many other countries once you end
up with debts public public and private
debts are in excess of three and a half
times the size of your annual output you
are Argentina
you know it's it's funny that the people
refer all the time back to the Lehman
crisis let's remember that this crisis
actually began in june two thousand
seven it fully became clear in august of
2007 that major financial institutions
were almost certainly on the brink of
insolvency to anybody who bothered to
think about the impacts of subprime
defaults on their balance sheets but we
were in denial for an extraordinarily
long time people both highly
sophisticated and lay people refuse to
believe what was happening which is why
i called it the great repression and we
stayed in denial until September more
than a year later of last year and then
we had the breakdown you'll notice how
psychological terms are very helpful
when economics fails as a discipline as
it clearly has so we retreat into the
realm of psychology after the repression
the breakdown we came out of denial and
we realized that probably more than one
major bank was insolvent and in
september-october the world went into
shock was deeply traumatic now we're in
the therapy phase and what therapy are
we using well it's very interesting
because we're using two quite
contradictory courses of therapy one is
the prescription of dr. Friedman Milton
Friedman that is and that's the therapy
that's being administered by the Federal
Reserve massive injections of liquidity
to avert the kind of banking crisis that
caused the Great Depression of the early
1930s I'm fine with that that's the
right thing to do but there's another
course of therapy that is simultaneously
being administered which is the therapy
prescribed by dr. cainnes john maynard
keynes and that therapy involves the
running of massive fiscal deficits in
excess of twelve percent of gross
domestic product this year and the
issuance therefore
a vast quantities of freshly minted
bonds now you know there's some medicine
in your drugs cabinet at home that has
past its sell-by date and I rather fear
at the risk of provoking the man sitting
on the other side of me that it says
1936 on the bottle of dr. Keynes's
medicine why do I think this because
there's a clear contradiction between
these two policies and we're trying to
have it both ways you can't be a
monetarist and a Keynesian
simultaneously at least I can't see how
you can because if the aim of the
monetarist policy is to keep interest
rates down to keep liquidity high the
effect of the Keynesian policy must be
to drive interest rates up after all
1.75 trillion dollars is an awful lot of
freshly minted Treasuries to land on the
bond market at a time of recession and I
still don't quite know who's going to
buy all this stuff it's certainly not
going to be the Chinese that works fine
in the good times but what I call CH
America the marriage between China and
America is sort of coming to an end
maybe it's going to end in a messy
divorce no the problem is that only the
Fed can buy these freshly minted
Treasuries and there is going to be I
predict in the weeks and months ahead a
very painful tug of war between our
monetary policy and our fiscal policy as
the markets realize just what a vast
quantity of bonds are going to have to
be absorbed by the financial system this
year that will tend to drive the price
of the bonds down that will tend to
drive up the interest rates and that
will have an effect also on mortgage
rates the precise opposite of what Ben
Bernanke is trying to achieve at the Fed
one final thought I don't want to make a
speech I'd rather engaging in a
conversation one final thought let's not
think of this as a purely American
phenomenon let's not be parochial if we
possibly can be this is a crisis of the
global economy I'd go so far as to say
it's a crisis of global
ization itself the US economy is not
going to contract the most this year
even if the worst projections of the IMF
turn out to be right two-point-six
percent contraction is far far less than
the shop already being inflicted on
Japan are on South Korea on Taiwan to
say nothing of the shock being inflicted
on Europe the German economy is
contracting that somewhere close to five
or six percent so we are faced not just
with a problem to be dealt with by
American policy we are faced with a
crisis of global proportions and it's
far from clear to me that the
prescriptions of dr. Friedman and dr.
cainnes together can solve that massive
global crisis Thank You neon so I think
there will be some disagreement others
panel professor Krugman well yeah I
think I should respond to that a bit let
me let me say actually I wish that we
actually still if people have remembered
that 1936 medication a little bit better
one of the problems we face and all of
this is what I have referred to as the
great forgetting we learned a great deal
about how economies can be in crisis
during the 1930s we took a number of
prophylactic measures to prevent
anything like that from happening ever
again and a very large part of how we
got into this crisis is that we forgot
all of that we forgot what our
grandfathers knew that we we forgot that
banking systems need to be very
carefully regulated and watched over
because banking crises can do terrible
damage we forgot that financial markets
are not in fact calm rational places
that they they really need to be
circumscribed and so we got into this
and one of the really disappointing
things I found as the crisis came upon
us is it also turns out that we've
forgotten a lot of the sort of basic
macroeconomics of this kind of problem
what what actually called a no
depression economics in the book that in
a much revised version I was reissued
last year
and I think it's actually it goes
directly to Neal's point here because
let's think about put put think about
what is actually happening to the global
economy right now what's happening is on
the one side there has been an abrupt
realization by many people that they
have too much debt that they are
over-indebted that they are not as rich
as they thought US households have seen
their net worth decline abruptly by 13
trillion dollars and there are similar
blows occurring around the world so the
people individual households want to
save again the United States has gone
from approximately a zero savings rate
two years ago up to about four percent
right now which is still below
historical norms but suddenly saving is
occurring that's saving ought to be
translated into investment but the
investment demand is not their housing
flat on its back because it was over
built housing bubbles not only in the
United States but across much of Europe
collapsed many businesses cannot get
access to capital because of the
breakdown of the financial system but
even those that do have access to
capital don't want to invest because
because demand consumer demand is not
there between the housing bust and the
sudden decision of consumers that maybe
they actually want to save after all
we're we have a world that with lots of
excess capacity and so if you this GDP
report that just came out says that
business fixed investment a
non-residential fixed investment
essentially business investment is
falling at a forty percent annual rate
so investment is falling through ground
and this causes a problem lots of people
want to save fast increase in the
desired savings not only the United
States but around the world combined
with a sharp decline in the amount that
the private sector is willing to invest
even at a zero interest rate or rather
even at a zero interest rate of four US
government debt which is what the
Federal Reserve has the most direct
impact on and one way to think about
what we have right now is a global
crisis
caused by a vast excess of desired
savings over willing investment we have
a global savings glut there's just not
enough you know another way to say is we
have a global shortage of demand those
are equivalent ways of saying the same
thing so we have this global savings
glut which is why there is in fact no
upward upward pressure on interest rates
there is more savings than we know what
to do with we ask the question where
will the savings come from to finance
these large US government deficits the
answer is from ourselves at the margin
the Chinese are not contributing at all
those extra savings are in effect the
savings that Americans wanted to do
anyway but that US business is not
willing to invest under current
conditions that is actually why
Keynesian policy works in the short run
it takes excess desired savings and
translates into them into some kind of
spending if the private sector won't do
it the government will there is actually
no contradiction between the Federal
Reserve's actions and the actions of the
US government with a fiscal stimulus
it's very much necessary to do both the
Federal Reserve is essentially going out
there and playing the role that the
private banking system is no longer
playing properly by buying a lot of
private securities the federal
government is going out there and
borrowing and playing the role that
businesses are not put are not willing
to play by by engaging investment all
that debt financed infrastructure
spending is it's basically filling the
hole left by the collapse in business
investment in the United States it's not
a there is not an access demand for
savings that is going to drive up
interest rates the only thing that might
drive up interest rates and this is a
real concern is that people may grow
dubious about the financial solvency of
governments so there are real problems
the United States is not there yet I
think we have probably a substantial
ways to run but other countries less so
Ireland is being forced to raise taxes
and cut spending because of fears about
its solvency despite a deep recession
the UK is fairly close to the edge
because people are worried about the
cost of financial bailout but but for
the United States that is certainly not
an issue now the the great concern I
have is that although we understand
these things fairly
well at least some of us do the band
actually was referring to Neil I'm
actually referring to I'm actually
referring to the to the 38 Republican
senators who said that the answer for
this is another round of Bush style tax
cuts they cost three trillion dollars of
the next decade but the the the great
problem we face is that the scale of the
crisis has overwhelmed the response that
this is not a qualitatively this is not
a crisis that we didn't know could
happen there was a lot of thought at the
Federal Reserve in the academic
profession there it's actually a little
nest of people at Princeton the early
years of this decade worrying about it
was me there was large fenced news now
at the riksbank and there was a guy
named Bernanke Ben Bernanke don't know
what happened to him we're worried about
something very much like this but what
we all had in mind was a much smaller
version of it and we thought that the
fair reserved by being vigorous and a
reasonable fiscal stimulus would head
off this kind of crisis at the pass and
what's actually happened is this crisis
has been so large the political process
has been sufficiently sluggish the
difficulties have been greater than
expected that we are actually deep in
this and yes there are some green shoots
things are getting worse more slowly but
we have not managed to head off a crisis
that could turn out to be self
reinforcing and leave us in this trap
for many many years thank you Paul
professor Rubin a you're up
well it's pretty clear right now the
worst financial crisis and economic
crisis and recession since the Great
Depression you know a number of us were
worrying about it awhile ago at this
point is becoming conventional wisdom
for example last year there was this
myth of decoupling that even if the US
would contract the rest of the world
would happily decouple from this US
economic contraction and usually people
say when the u.s. sneezes the rest of
the world catches a cold this number and
the US was not just needing at a severe
case of drowning pneumonia and first the
financial contagion of the real
continued has led to a economic
contraction from the u.s. to the
eurozone the UK Australia New Zealand
Canada Japan two-thirds of global gdp
advanced economies contracting and now a
hard landing also in emerging markets
with severe recession in many of them
slow down or growth increases like China
and risk of outright financial crisis
currency banking sovereign in a number
of emerging market economies so where
are we now and what needs to be done you
know people are talking about these
green shoots of spring about second
derivatives of economic activity
becoming positive meaning the rate of
contraction is not accelerating but just
decelerating and therefore we're going
to reach about them sooner rather than
later glimmers of hope but if you look
at the data in some sense and you look
at the debate about the shape of this
recession we are in a severe recession
right now in the u.s. a year ago the
consensus was Arjun this recession will
be short and shallow v-shaped lasting
maybe eight pounds like they last two
1991 and 2001 and people like myself and
other were suggesting that given
imbalances and the financial system the
over boring and over leveraged by
households and even corporates this will
be more like a u-shape recession 24
months or so and I would argue that I
was Gargan they will even risk of a
something more severe a l-shaped
recession or depression like the one
that Japan experience after the collapse
of its a real estate and equity bubble
in the 1990s i would say that right
now it's obvious that the v's out of the
window we're already in the 17 months of
a severe recession is already twice as
long as the previous two if this ratio
is over even by the end of this year
will be 24 months ending three times as
long and more like six times as deep as
any previous one in terms of output
collapse and if you look at employment
industrial production and other things
even worse than that looks like a almost
like a near depression so the v's out of
the window I would say that the good
news is probably the very aggressive
actions by the policymaker in US and
around the world i think that six months
ago was a risk of a new depression and
the policymaker finally got religion
looked into the abyss the conv is
contracting six percent plus us around
the world and now they decided use all
most of the weapons in their Arsenal's
guns bazookas missiles artillery you
name it monetary fiscal credit 20
different programs because of that I
think that the risk of a near depression
has been somewhat reduced I don't think
that there is zero probability but we
probably are not gonna end up in there
nearly depression we learn some of the
lessons has Paul said from the Great
Depression even from Japan however now
the consensus is becoming optimistic
again and says that we're going to go
from minus six percent growth to
positive growth in the second half of
the year meaning the recession is gonna
be over in in june by q4 they estimate
that growth is going to be positive two
percent the next year more than two
percent so back to potential now
compared to these new concerns that got
it wrong in the past my views are much
more bearish I would agree that the rate
of economic interaction is flowing down
if you had the keep on having the free
fall of the last two quarters will end
up another Great Depression and the
policy action reducing that but we're
still contracting at a pretty fast rate
I see the economy contracting all the
way to the end of the year so reaching
from minus six minus 2 naught plus 2 and
next year the growth rate of the economy
is going to be so low 0.5% is opposed to
two percent loss of the consensus and
then employment rates already dizzy is
going to be above ten percent and more
likely close to eleven percent next year
the living next year is going to feel
like
recession even if we were technically
out of the recession and the outlook for
Europe and Japan would you this year
next year is even worse so most advanced
economies are going to do even worse
than the United States for a number of
reasons structural factors in Japan week
policy response in the case of the
eurozone now the financial problem the
financial system I've you are still
sitting here many banks are still
insolvent I agree if you don't want to
end up like Japan with zombie banks just
bleep broadly suggest is better to do
what Sweden did take over the bank's
clean them up separate good and bad
assets and sell them back in short order
to the private sector now on the
question of the policy responses will be
the of a debate between Neal and n poll
and I think that when i'm closer to the
views of a poll I think there is some
grain of truth about what Neal says in
the following sense there is no
inconsistency between monetary easing
and fiscal easing both of them should be
stimulating demand and the monetary
easing should be leading also to
restoration of credit of course in a
situation which the prongs of the
economic problems of not just a
liquidity but also of solvency
traditional monetary policy doesn't work
you also have to do unconventional stuff
and you have to fix the banks and we did
the fiscal stimulus because every
component of a grid the man is
collapsing consumption residential
investment capex spending
non-residential construction inventories
exports the only thing can go up and
sustain the economy for the time being
is fiscal policy however there are
caveats the cavities monetary policy
cannot resolve problems of credit first
of all secondly fiscal policy is not
without cost we need in a short run
we're going to add about nine trillion
dollars to US public debt if you think
about the problem of the economy leader
said is the end of an age of leverage is
not really there is no deleveraging with
all the liabilities of the households of
the banks of the corporates and now we
decided to socialize these losses and to
put them on the back of the balance
sheet of the government that's why the
public debt is rising when you had that
problem you have to convert it into
equity that's what you do with corporate
is to actually convert some my unsecured
debt into equity that's what you should
do with the bank's take them secured
creditors income
claims into equity the same thing you
could do with their house also reduce
their mortgages and have an upside for
the credit in terms of a warrant what
we're doing is not that that into equity
conversion but we're doing is piling
more debt on top of more debt and at
some point the back of the solvent is
going to break and when that's going to
happen it's going to be a disaster so we
need fiscal Stephen short run but we
have to worry about the long run to
thank you no real there will be time to
but there will be a plenty of time to
apply some of this out mr. Soros well I
think it's fairly obvious by now that
you're in a difficult situation there
are two features that I think they
deserve to be pointed out one is that
the financial system as we know it
actually collapsed after the bankruptcy
of lehman brothers and sep tember 15 the
the financial system really ceased to
function and had to be put an artificial
life support and at the same time the
financial shock had a tremendous effect
on the real economy and the real economy
went into a freefall and that was global
and international trade was the one that
was actually collapsed more than
economic activity it was the worst hit
the other feature is that the system
collapsed of its own weight and that
contradicted the prevailing view the
governing view about financial markets
namely that they tend towards
equilibrium and that equilibrium is
disturbed by extraneous forces outside
shocks and and
you have then divergencies from that
equilibrium but they occur in a random
fashion but basically markets are
self-correcting and that paradigm has
been proven to be false and so we are
dealing not only with the collapse of
financial system but also with the
collapse of a worldview and a collapse
like this generally events always
outpace people's ability to understand
what's happening so the response is
always lagging behind the problem and
policies that could have worked at one
point no longer work at the next so
that's the situation that the President
Obama inherited now in these
circumstances he is faced with a double
objective two objectives one you have to
arrest the collapse arrest and if
possible reverse the collapse a second
you have to reconstruct the system
because it cannot be reconstructed the
way it was it can't be restored so this
is a different situation and when people
compare this with other previous
financial crisis they're making a
mistake now the interesting thing is
that what you need to do in the short
term is almost exactly the opposite of
what needs to be done in the long term
because the obviously the problem was
excessive leverage but when you have a
color collapse of credit you then have
to and there's only one source of credit
that is still credible and that's the
state the Federal Reserve and the
Treasury and then you have to actually
inject a lot more leverage and gap and
money effectively have to print money as
fast as you can expand the balance sheet
of the Federal Reserve increase the
national debt and that is in fact what
what has been done which is the right
thing to do but then you have to do once
the this policy is successful you will
then have to drain the money supply as
fast as the accredited experience so in
the circumstances I would say that
policy generally lagged behind events we
were behind the curve now that the the
freefall is moderating and the space of
the collapse has more or less occurred I
think we are we have a good hope that
policy will in fact catch up with events
and I actually hope it will be very
interesting what's going to happen in
the next ten days if we the stress test
because that's basically where the
policy has been lagging behind in
recapitalising the banks and that's
where most of the confusion and distress
comes from but if the census is is
really used to to give a realistic
picture of the banks I think that the
good banks will be able to raise money
and that will narrow the problem and
then the government can deal with the
recapitalization and then we avoid the
danger that we I think we are all aware
of of a zombie banks that deep in the
hole that are going to have to earn
their way out of that hole and will
continue to weigh on the economy for a
very long time George Thank You
professor Wells we have done this in
alphabetical order in case you hadn't
noticed this and I'm sure rob has dealt
with being a w for a long time yes and I
have the advantage of then following up
and being able to to follow up on what
others have said so it's fine by me I
don't have any particular expertise
about what the economy is going to do
today or six months from now I don't
have any particular expertise on how
viable the green shoots are although i
will say that I'm something what's
skeptical because as I've said to other
people the rate at which things were
declining during the first quarter means
that if that decline kept on pretty soon
we'd hit the Stone Age so it had to
moderate at some point however
moderating is not the same thing as a
recovery and as Paul and others have
said I'm not really sure where a
recovery is going to come from but given
that i also want to focus on a somewhat
different point i do think that for
policy reasons it's important to figure
out whether there are green shoots and
how viable they are but i think that an
emphasis exclusively on that leads us to
the possibility of not solving some deep
structural problems what I'm really
concerned about is what do we do to
prevent ourselves from being in a
situation 10 years from now say if we do
have green shoots say if we do start to
have recovery phase by this time in
twenty ten or
a little bit later although I do think
that somewhat unrealistic what prevents
us from if the banks have limped along
and the stock market is back up 10 years
from now having gone back in the
situation of excessive leverage and
having an implosion of the financial
sector and these huge global
repercussions and in order to answer
that question or at least examine it I
have to take you through a little
economics tonight and a little bit of
history I want to go back to what Paul
said about the global savings glut the
global savings glut is what drove
interest rates down to historically low
levels and if you know much about
macroeconomics you know that housing is
very sensitive to the interest rate and
therefore a housing bubble was
practically foreordained with an
extended period of low interest rates
all right but you'll also notice that
the bubble and housing hasn't been just
in the United States it's been in places
like Spain it's been in Eastern Europe
it's been in the UK it's been in Ireland
it's been in Iceland so Paul is really
correct when we talk about a global
savings glut a global savings glut that
yes impacted us very badly but it's
impacted other countries as well so I
think in order to prevent us from
experiencing this catastrophe and
another say 10 years we need to look at
the origins of the global savings glut
and now yes there are some differences
at how those were actually manifest
between the different countries and
those manifestations are important but
let's look for a moment at the global
savings glut on a global level all right
so if we back up and I think this story
starts really about in the 80s because
in the 80s during the Reagan years we
began to experience chronic fiscal
deficits and we began to abdicate our
responsibility to raise tax
revenue that could sustainably finance
government now in order to do that we
had to borrow and who did we borrow from
we borrowed from countries that were
running persistent trade surpluses and
going to niles point that's China that
is also Germany and that's also Japan
and as we continue to run these deficits
these countries by keying on growing
through exports there grew to be this
symbiotic relationship as niall says
this Comerica but it was on several
different fronts between the net
exporters such as China Japan and
Germany and the net importers of capital
the largest of course in the United
States all right this import of capital
allowed us to consistently live beyond
our means first through the fiscal
deficits not raising enough tax revenue
to finance the government and then also
through ultimately the leverage that we
used in housing and in commercial real
estate and in leveraged buyouts and this
continued and it grew because there was
nothing anywhere along the line which
anyone would say halt I think that we
had a situation in which we are governed
by in its administration Republican
administrations in which it was in their
interest not to call a halt to these
persistent and balances the persistent
imbalances led us to pretend that we
could keep borrowing and not having
sufficient tax revenue to pay for the
government and also if your house prices
are rising if your stock market is going
up which is of course it's going to
happen if you have cheap money it puffs
up the value of the assets then that
disguises a lot of other structural
problems such as rising inequality all
right such as corruption so at this
we also get an increase in the financial
take of the economy as we have this
inflow of capital from abroad the
financial sector in the United States
grows larger and larger relative to the
rest of economy so we have what i call a
financialization where the gdp is tilted
disproportionally towards the financial
sector all right how do we start to get
out of this well it's difficult all
right we have a situation which i find
that we're often we're in many ways
almost adverse to bringing up the
situation that we find the codependent
situation that we find ourselves in with
the net exporting countries I thought it
was quite interesting a few weeks ago
when the Chinese many Chinese officials
were saying that it was proper and it
was good economically the u.s. continued
to run persistent trade imbalances with
China that the remedy did not need to be
appreciated that we should continue
doing things as we always have and that
the US should make sure that the value
of Chinese assets were not diminished by
fall on the dollar okay um I thought
that was very interesting because it
really was a situation in which it was
clear that this was not a sustainable
relationship but no one was willing to
say that and no one was willing to say
that clearly in terms of the Chinese so
I think in order to get out of the
situation that we're in we're going to
have to address these global imbalances
and I know it's easy for me to say that
as I sitting here I'm sure in my Chinese
made silk silk blouse but we're going to
have to start to address chronic trade
imbalances you might very well see a
shift towards more protectionism we're
going to have to actually do something
about raising taxes so that we can
sustain gun
rather than depending upon borrowing
abroad I think that we're going to have
to start stepping into our role one that
we abdicated as as true managers and
guardians in the global economy and that
we're going to have to start to grow up
globally and economically Robin thank
you very much we're now going to have a
conversation among ourselves i encourage
you all to talk up and even intervene
but also to talk quickly i I did want to
go to Neil however since it seems to me
the consensus was against neo and I want
to give him an opportunity to defend
himself I think most people think the
government did what it had to in terms
of adopting a serious stimulus despite
the debt Neil when you respond to the
comments and then we'll have a little
discussion on that and then I'd very
much like to move to the longer term
that Robin was introducing and how we
really organize the American economy in
the future but let's take it from here
well if you listen carefully to what
Paul Krugman said he actually agreed
with me because what he said was this
everything was just fine as long as the
financial credibility of the United
States wasn't called into question but
my point is that it will be called into
question Paul of course it will even if
the administration's crazily optimistic
forecasts for growth turn out to be
right yes it's going to be a three
percent growth rate next year four
percent the year after that four point
six percent year after that if you
believe those numbers you'll believe
absolutely anything but they are there
in the administration's budget document
even if those numbers turn out to be
true the gross federal debt will rise
over the next five to ten years to
around a hundred percent of gross
domestic product but since those numbers
are clearly wrong and the trend growth
rate of the US will be much closer to
one percent than 24 it seems reasonable
to anticipate a much more rapid
explosion of federal debt to somewhere
in the region of 140
one hundred and fifty percent of gross
domestic product now Paul tried to
reassure you that the rising savings
rays would absorb easily all of this
additional debt but I have to point out
that what he said was misleading even if
the private savings rate rebounded to
its highest point in the post-war period
it would still account for no more than
five percent of gross domestic product
but this year's deficit as I said
earlier is likely to be north of twelve
percent of gross domestic product so I
hate to teach arithmetic to a Nobel
laureate it doesn't quite add up the Fed
has committed itself to buying three
hundred billion dollars worth of
Treasuries this year but clearly it will
have to buy a great many more than that
remember one point seven or so trillion
dollars are coming onto the market and
you just assume that the credibility of
the United States in the eyes of
Americans as well as foreign investors
is going to withstand this at some point
you know the United States does start to
look like a Latin American economy not
only two people abroad but maybe people
at home if the fed's balance sheet
explodes to up to three or four trillion
dollars who knows how big it could get
at what point of people stop believing
in the United States dollar as a reserve
currency or even as a store of value for
their own savings and these are the
points but it seems to me the economists
who are in a majority on this panel are
dodging there's a fundamental problem
here which could be addressed if there
were any commitment in the part of this
administration to root and branch
long-run fiscal reform an attempt to put
the United States on a sound fiscal
footing but I see no sign of it at all
the idea that we make a hundred million
dollars worth of savings or whatever
ridiculous number the president came up
with it the other day testifies to the
fundamental unserious pneus that is the
problem in Washington today let allow
Paul and others to respond
boy oh dear oh dear indeed let's talk
national income accounting offstage okay
you forgot about retained earnings by
definition savings and the economy as a
whole are equal to investment the very
whacked in the world very our trade
deficit is falling or rising the very
fact that we have a depressed economy
despite these deficits tells you that
the supply of savings from the private
sector is in fact the desired supply of
savings from the private sector is in
fact greater than the amount of the
federal government is borrowing if that
were not true we would be seeing in fact
an excess and demand and that's not
happening I do worry very different
things there's there's a question of is
there are more demand is the the amount
of borrowing that everybody collectively
businesses and the government together
greater than the amount that essentially
the the rest of the economy is willing
to lend which is not a problem because
in it as I to just go back to the
essence of this kind of recession is
precisely that the amount that
collectively we want to save is greater
than the amount that collectively we
want to invest that is the problem can't
get around that there's a very different
question which is the long run solvency
and I do worry about that I worry and
the the numbers I would disagree very
much with you about those numbers but
the but there is a fact we are currently
at about death of about sixty percent of
GDP we have in the past been as high as
100 percent of GDP at the end of World
War two without having a crisis but your
ability to go that high does depend upon
people's belief that you will behave
responsibly and that is somewhat in
question it less so I hope now that
we've had some regime change in this
country that it was in the past but it
is a problem so there are certainly
limits and that's is one of the concerns
but I think we do need to get these
things straight because one of the
things that is a problem is intellectual
confusion unfortunately while there are
many many real obstacles
to dealing with this crisis it is not
easy to deal with one of the really
terrifying things for me has been the
extent to which just sheer
misunderstanding misunderstanding of of
issues that were settled 70 years ago
has been crippling a lot of the policy
debate and we do need to get these
things straight can I switch to the
longer term just for a moment can I come
back to you on the long-term because
Maria wants to talk about the decision
quickly and then I think it will get to
that yes I think the debate is a bit
about what needs to be done the
short-term versus the long-term then the
lesson of the great depression is pretty
clear the Great Depression started the
stock market crash and it became great
depression by 33 because of four reasons
one with in believing cut the cyclical
monetary policy the money supply
contracted rather being eased interested
or not falling that made the credit
crunch wars to nobody believed in
counter-cyclical fiscal policy the
general theory of Keynes was written
only in 36 therefore were raising taxes
and cutting spending maintains balanced
budget that made the recession even more
severe three-d-- was this believe in
creative destruction let the bank's
collapse thousands of them collapse the
credit crunch became even worse and for
seventy-five percent of house of the
mortgage default abide 33 on their
mortgage we could they couldn't paid so
stock market crash became a great
depression then you add currency wars
than your trade words then yet
protection is then your capital controls
then your default by countries that do a
raise of nasty authoritarian regimes in
German in Italy in Japan in Spain and
then when it up in World War two right
so those are the consequence of not
taking the right policy actions and the
right policy actions mean in the short
run that you do the right steam was now
i agree aware that we have to worry
about the long run we're going to
finance this budget deficits by printing
money we may have high inflation
hyperinflation that's what happened in
Germany in the 30s in the Viper republic
and so on if we are having large budget
deficits an increase in the public that
we don't know there is going to be 5 30
or 10 30 whatever eventually the only
few ways of resolving at that problem
either you default on it like can't say
like Argentina do we've never
done it or use the inflation tax to wipe
out the real value of the debt or you
have to raise taxes and cut government
spending and given the size of the
deficits over time that's going to be a
painful policing political choice so we
need the stimulus in the short run we
need to have the basis for a medium-term
fiscal sustainability and during the
liquidity otherwise when I have problems
over the medium term Delta bill deep no
I think that if you look at the
President's budget there is if you look
at it carefully a potential answer to
the dilemma you pose and that is he's
proposed 634 billion dollars for health
care that won't get there that's not
going to get there so that means he's
going to have to do something on
Medicare and Medicaid which are very
large entitlements and I could see him
with the promise of covering most
Americans how many 95 96 % saying we
can't get there now we have to do some
things on Medicare and Medicaid and when
he does those things on Medicare and
Medicaid it shows that the growth of
those programs which are driving
entitlements are is much less steep it's
easy to deal with social security and
then you've sent the message to the
world economy that you are a responsible
fiscal government and then you might get
money from China Japan other countries
even though the Chinese now you know if
he's have 0 then they used to finance
fifty percent of our deficit essentially
and now it's like an eleven percent and
when it goes to 1.8 trillion it's going
to be less than eleven percent
foreigners are going to have less than
eleven which brings us back to Paul's
point which is we don't really need the
foreigners because we have increased our
savings meaning that savings can go into
Treasuries and therefore finance the
budget deficit but if savings going to
Treasuries of savings aren't going into
investing in
buddies the produced jobs and growth so
it creates a dilemma but I believe that
if you took a look at the budget deficit
or the budget you see the beginning of
an answer and an awareness on the part
administration that this is the issue
that has to be addressed George do you
think there's a big inflation awaiting
us at their big rise in inflation yeah
yes look we are going to end up with a
big increase in the national debt but
let's face it for 25 years we have been
consuming more than we were producing
the that death was accumulated over 25
years of living beyond our means and
what has happened it accumulated mainly
in the housing sector and ever end the
financial sector and that's now being
nationalized it's them for a little bit
unfortunate so far we have only
nationalized the liabilities of the
banks and not their assets but of course
that's sort of kind of a trap via phone
person as we say I've got it lemon
socialism that site belongs to the
public so so and however and so I think
it's right that we are extending a
government credit to replace the
collapsing credit and we have we are
currently facing at the deflationary
situation when credit restarts suddenly
there will be a flip-flop where the fear
of deflation will be replaced by the
fear of inflation and the pressure for
interest rates to rise will be very very
strong at that time the Fed would be
ill-advised to keep on buying long-term
that because that would
push other people out from buying to
that and they would have to monetize it
all and you would have runaway inflation
so therefore the rise in interest rates
is going to choke off the recovery and
so we are facing now a period of stop go
or stagflation similar but more severe
than what we faced in in in in the in
the 80s success the 70 suicide I get my
deck is wrong but but story in here
that's why you have a historian here
George yes to get the decades right
right but but that is a favorable
outcome compared to what would have
would have happened if we didn't do what
we are doing let's let Jeff can I can
ask a question because it seems to me
the analogies are being drawn here with
various different decades Paul seems to
think that the 1930s apply of course
when Keynes's rising globalization had
completely broken down and as he said
his recipe was really intended for a
closed economy not an open economy Paul
talks in wonderfully national terms I
noticed this in your columns Paul but
the world's one economy now we have to
think of it as one economy for as long
as globalization holds up now it seems
to me a real problem here we're looking
at the wrong place and the wrong time
for remedies why is this not Japan what
is the difference between what we are
doing now and what the Japanese did
after 1989 they did practically exactly
what we're doing zero interest rate
policy and quantitative easing a massive
increase in the public debt huge
deficits in order to try to restart the
economy and of course the propping up of
the banking system rather than the kind
of restructuring of bank bank debts that
has been proposed by so I think that's
the difference let's let Paul anti right
so thank you only as an ad no actually
I'm the banking side we are
even alarmingly like the Japanese in
fact in many ways now the funny thing is
that we came into this I by the way I
think both the 1930s and Japan's Lost
Decade are entirely relevant that's very
much the framework in which I think and
and a lot of what I'm saying really our
global issues and I hope we have a
chance to get to this because it is a it
is a global savings glut the world as a
whole has more desired savings than the
world as a whole is willing to invest
that's our problem right now that's the
immediate problem and if I were going to
say the the u.s. the amazing thing about
US policy is that we have policy makers
who thought a lot about Japan tremendous
emphasis at the Fed tremendous emphasis
on learning from the japanese lesson
decision we were not going to do what
the japanese did that we were not going
to have a fiscal response that was just
enough to prop up the economy but not
enough to really generate a cut recovery
that we're not going to let the bank's
slide sort of propping them up but not
actually fixing them and then faced with
the actual crisis what we have is a
fiscal response that's enough to prop up
the economy but not enough to generate a
real recovery and what we're doing is
letting the bank's slide propping them
up enough to keep them for collapsing
but not enough to really fix them so the
we've actually turned Japanese in spite
of an enormous determination at least
verbally not to do that that's what
scares me about this that we have we
this case we thought we had learned from
history and and in the event have proved
unable to avoid repeating it and that is
that is a very frightening thing so on
that I think we're in agreement but at
the point about the Japanese is not that
they did too too much on either of these
fronts but they failed to do enough
which was the policy consensus well if
you asked what Larry Summers was saying
before was you have to have a Powell
doctrine you have to hit this kind of
problem with overwhelming force and what
was instead got is a Vietnam style
escalation let me let Muriel's make a
quick comment on this and then let's go
on to broader issues about the future
some sense I actually think we're trying
to avoid the mistakes of Japan Japan
waited two years until the cut interest
after the bursting of their bubble we
have done it very aggressively than 20
very fast Japan went half-heartedly into
quantitive easing we've done it big time
Japan reverse the zero interest rate
policy too soon that was a mistake Japan
waited two years after the bursting of
the Bible to do any fiscal stimulus and
then instead of doing infrastructure to
build marinas in every fishing village
so there was not productive investment
Japan imposed a consumption tax too
early there was a contraction of fiscal
policy Japan kept tumbi banks and zombie
you know corporates alive for eight
years until 98 we're not doing enough
but II getting to the cries were doing
more than Japan did in Japan it
structured rigid is like lifetime
employment we don't have so in some
sense there are things we can learn from
Japan and do more front-loaded more
aggressive more consistent we're doing
some of those mistakes on the banks but
then there is a difference between us in
Japan as well we have 15 minutes
unfortunately Robin wants to make a
comment on this but I also want to ask
you to begin to talk quickly about the
future and trying to correct these embed
imbalances and you said my favorite
words which makes me very unpopular
raise taxes in the future so let's talk
a little bit about let's get into that
argument give everybody a reasonable
chance to make a contribution all right
I wanted to start off by responding to
Neal's point about this being global
economy yes it is a global economy but
it's a dysfunctional global economy
because in this sort of Freeman IDE view
of the way that the open economy free
global trade and free global capital
flows would operate you had flexible
exchange rates and a flexible exchange
rates would allow a way to equilibrate
these these these surpluses and these
deficits so that they weren't persistent
what we have now is a system of
complicit cheating because we have a
remem be that needs to be revalued
upwards we have germany that's running
persistent surpluses we have Japan
that's running persistent surpluses if
we had truly flexible exchange rates
that wouldn't be occurring what happened
to the argentineans when they got blown
was because they were pegged to the
dollar so we have to realize that we are
in a dysfunctional situation unless we
actually do something to correct that we
are on the road to having that happen
again now as I was saying before about
taxes needing to go up taxes need to go
up because we have to have first of all
a credible commitment that we are going
to pay off these debts that we where we
are running up and that's really a
political question more so than an
economic question I think it's also it
also though goes into this issue of we
need to be clear and we need to treat
government as a something that is
sustainable and I think it also having a
larger government at this point can help
deal with the problem that Paul was
bringing up which is that with a global
savings glut we have a situation which
there's more savings than profitable
investment opportunities so if you're an
investor what's your expected rate of
return minus and that's one way of how
in effecting a minus rate of return is
to invest in the stock market and have
it all go poo okay so we could be
subject to these booms and bust as long
as we're and what it does it gives us
over the average a negative rate of
return one way of trying to get around
that is by actually having the
government to the investing in things
that we don't we aren't good at
investing as individuals like
environmental policy like universal
health care like better education like
better infrastructure I'll stop let me
thank thank you um let me ask George
George what should the future American
economy look like and what is the role
in government in that both public
investment taxes and rear egg y elation
of the financial sector or restructuring
the financial setting well but we have
to start be recognizing that the
prevailing view is false that Marcus
actually our bubble drone they create
bubbles therefore they have to be
regulated the authorities regulators
have to
accept responsibility for preventing
asset bubbles from growing too big
they've expressly rejected that saying
that if the markets don't know how can
the regulators know and of course they
can't so they're bound to be wrong but
they get feedback from the market and
then they can adjust because they have
not done enough or reverse because they
haven't done too much so this means that
is not enough to regulate the money
supply you have to regulate the credit
and that means using tools that have
fallen into disuse you have margin
requirements minimum capital
requirements which of course you still
do but you actually have to vary them
took to counteract the prevailing mood
of the market because Marcus do have
moods and it is the job of the
regulators actually you know this is
called irrational it was called
irrational exuberance but it should be
recognized that is that exuberance
actually is quite rational that when you
see when I see a bubble beginning
forming I jump on it because that's how
I make money so it's perfectly rational
what's going on right now occurs so it
is the job of the regulators regulate
however we should try not to go
overboard towards regulation because
while markets are imperfect regulators
are even more imperfect because not only
are they human but they're also
bureaucratic and they are also subject
to political influences so we want to
keep regulation to a minimum but it has
to recognize that markets are inherently
unstable real
on this show of regulation of course we
go into cycles you know we had the Great
Depression and then we imposed many
actually useful regulations both of the
financial system and of the real economy
some of it became excessive and then a
period of deregulation started actually
even before reagan in touch there was
jimmy carter that started some of the
deregulation of some parts of the
economy and then we went to a stream in
believe that a deregulated economy is
best because as george said when there
are market failure dries to be
prudential regulation supervision of the
financial system and economic activity
we started believing that
self-regulation is best means no
regulation we believed in market
discipline that means no discipline
because there is irrational exuberance
we relied on internal disk management
models but nobody's listening to his
managers when the risk takers are making
all the profits and then we relied on
rating agencies that had totally
conflicts of interest being paid by
those they were supposed to be rating so
the entire model of self-regulation
market discipline now has collapsed we
have to go to a world in which is going
to be more prudential provisional
regulation of the financial system the
other thing has happened because of this
deregulation we've gone through these
booming bass that become more frequent
and more virulent you know the only
piece of time in which the US has bring
going fast was in the eighties with the
real estate bubble when bust S&L crisis
1991 recession then with the tech bubble
went bust and wedded 2001 recession then
we created with easy money is accredited
in lack of regulation they credit in the
housing bubble now with a bigger
economic and financial crisis i think
the challenge for the US economy is can
we grow without excessive credit than
leverage can we go in a more sustainable
way and what are going to be the sectors
of the corner gives us sustainable
long-term growth i think that's an open
question oh I want to adjust this
variety of issues gosh there are so many
things that that I'd like to talk about
let's talk about where we ought to be
when we come out of this which God knows
went but when we come um so let me stand
there i think there are two big
structural changes that we'd want to see
one is we need to define analyze the
economy we went from an economy in which
about four percent of gdp came for
the financial sector to an economy in
which eight percent of gdp comes from
the financial sector in which at its
peak forty-one percent of profits were
being earned by by the financial sector
and there is no reason to believe that
anything productive happened as a result
of all of that we had all of these
extremely highly compensated bankers who
were essentially just finding new ways
to offload risks on to other people and
it and we really need to shrink this
back down we need a we need we need a
boring banking sector again this all of
this high finances has turned out to be
just destructive and that's partly a
matter of regulation that we but we need
to accept that that we were not going to
go back and by the way also a political
economy vicious circle here because as
the financial sector got increasingly
bloated his political clout also grew so
in fact deregulation bread bloated
finance which bread more deregulation
what's bread this this monster that that
ate the world economy the other thing
and this is a little bit off but I
things we're saying one thing not to
miss is the importance of a strong
social safety net by most accounts most
projections say that the European
European Union is actually going to have
a somewhat deeper recession this year in
the United States so in terms of macro
management they're actually doing a poor
job and there are various reasons for
that the European Central Bank is too
conservative Europeans have been too
slow to do fiscal stimulus but the human
suffering is going to be much greater on
this side of the Atlantic because
Europeans don't lose their health care
when they lose their jobs they don't
find themselves with essentially no
support once their trivial unemployment
check has fallen off we have got nothing
underneath when Americans lose their
jobs they fold into the abyss that does
not happen in other advanced countries
it does not happen I might sort of want
to say in civilized countries and
there are people say that we should not
be worrying about things like universal
health care in the crisis we need to
solve the crisis but this is exactly the
kind of time when the importance of
having a decent social safety net is
driven home to everybody which makes it
a very good time to actually move ahead
on these other things thank you Paul
Neil future the role of government and
Bill you got the first word and you're
going to get the last word well I tell
you what I feel depressed after what
I've heard tonight I don't know about
you ladies and gentlemen we we are now
contemplating a massive expansion of the
state to substitute for the private
sector because that's the only thing pol
thinks will deliver growth we're going
to rear egg you late the markets we're
going to go back to those good old days
oh yeah you you applaud because you
think that's a great idea where were you
in the 1970s just just from where were
you in the 1970s when all these
wonderful regulations were in place I
don't remember that going too smoothly
but what a why else are we gonna do
we're going to print money almost
limitless Lee will print money that's
going to be fine too and then when we're
done with that we're going to raise
taxes what a fabulous package we have in
store for us you know back in late two
thousand seven I was asked what my big
concern was and i said my concern is
that we're going to get the 1970s for
fear of the 1930s and that is exactly
where the majority of people on this
panel are steering this country and it's
very easy to forget in your iron
indignation at the failure of the market
it's very easy to forget where the true
mainsprings of economic growth lie
ladies and gentlemen the lesson of
economic history is very clear economic
growth does not come from state-led
infrastructure investment it comes from
technological innovation and gains in
productivity and these things come from
the private sector not from the state if
you want to try the Soviet model fine
by all means I like if you got
huh but wait a second wait a second if
you if you won't let me finish and
comment wait did we why I think
everybody on this panel is now biting
his tongue and let's let bill well just
in cluding myself Jeff we let you know
which led nowhere your fine work no no
no come on Nell let's like you see where
were your doing you a good turn by not
extending this ten minutes dell has the
final way know where you go Jeff Jeff we
know where you stand on big government
and remember you rule is that of anchor
the kick the critical point here is
please kneel my role of anchor is now to
pass it on to bill I think I think we
understand her very good nope so as we
look at the future one of the main
things that we have to do I agree with
Paul on social safety net health
education in particular but we also have
to look at the mistakes policymakers
made in the last ten years I mean you
know it's not news that people are
greedy that's kind of nature human
nature it is that we made conscious
decisions not to put limits on that
natural human impulse what were the
mistakes in 1998 we allowed investment
banks banks insurance companies to
combine we eliminated glass-steagall why
was glass-steagall put into law because
the last time we didn't limit greed we
got into trouble the Great Depression
and the second mistake was in 1999 the
explicit decision by an administration
and a Congress not to regulate
derivatives in particular credit default
swaps that in 2002 were worth one
trillion dollars and today are worth
thirty three trillion dollars and that
decision not to eliminate derivatives
created the following sequence you
mortgages affect a thousand mortgages as
a mortgage-backed security a thousand
mortgage-backed securities as collateral
debt obligation a thousand collateral
debt obligations is a CDO squared and
ensuring each one of those tranches is
part of that 33 trillion dollars and we
decided not to regulate it 384 people in
the London office of AIG destroyed and
are not destroyed destroyed I'm not to
blame for AIG you no no no why did I
accept this invitation no no no I said I
said the London office it could have
been hamburg 33 people 100 384 people in
the London office doing the derivatives
destroyed a company that had armed
16,000 employees in 120 countries why
because there was no regulation at all
third decision 2004 the SEC allowed
banks to go from 10 to 1 leverage to 32
1 leverage and guess what once they were
allowed to do it they did it and so if
we're going to look at the future we
might think of undoing those three
mistakes and we might want to remember
that the Chairman the Federal Reserve is
supposed to remove the punch from the
party when it gets out of control and
that did not happen in the Greenspan
years the opposite thank you Bill Gary
just the brief point on Neil's point on
socialism the previous administration
was so ideologically free-market less
affair while weds capitalism did he
believe in any Prudential Regulation
supervision that he created such a big
financial economic disaster did they
turn out to be the Socialists because
they were the one they implemented all
these policies that were now govern
intervention it would be more pragmatic
less ideological and believing
government can provide the safety net
government can provide potential
revelations provision we would not have
this mess and we'll have an accomplished
vanish as a market economy where the
governor will have its own role that was
the problem Muriel thank you thank you
all very much thank a Neil Ferguson for
being a brave soul up here I would like
to thank the editor and publisher of my
favorite publication the New York Review
of Books